welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz
today i'm very excited to be joined by
rachel maine who is
a director at ventura consulting who are
a boutique recruiting agency operating
both in the technology and business
change markets
and the professional services markets
and rachel
entered the recruitment industry
straight out of university in 2009
where she joined a company called ruling
id where she progressed from trainee to
an executive within five years
rachel then went on to manage and lead a
team focused on
the business change in iit
transformation space before joining
ventura consulting as an associate
director in 2017
and then since then over the last four
years rachel's been involved in helping
grow the business
and also is kind of responsible for
supporting a delivery team of five
consultants
rachel thank you for uh joining me on
the podcast thanks for having me hisham
it's a real privilege
great to be here amazing so where we
always like to start
is in your opinion what characteristics
what characteristics and traits do you
think make up a highly
successful recruitment consultant the
million-dollar question
i mean there are so many
um if we were to focus i think first and
foremost and this
goes across well for all of us really is
positivity
i think it encompasses a lot of
other traits of course like your typical
resilience and whatnot but i think
unless you have a positive attitude
then it's going to be difficult for you
to succeed
um it's about flipping like a negative
situation and turning it into positive i
think that's so important so having that
mindset is really going to help you
um so if you bit of a negative person
i'm not saying recruitment isn't for you
but you maybe just work on that mindset
and i think you'll notice
that things get so much better for you
um i touched on it resilience of course
you have to be able to get back on the
horse as they say if the deal drops out
or you get a rejection
um i think self-awareness is so
important as well
um having that strong emotional
intelligence
um being professional of course also
having some personality and sense of
humor
i think marrying those two i think there
are so many people that
maybe a bit too professional and i think
it's always good to have have that
personality because i think
clients really like it it does make you
stand apart um
and then finally fluid intelligence i
mean you have to be very reactionary
every day in recruitment's different i
think you need to have that in order to
be able to survive really
um quite a few things but i said they're
the most important
traits in my perspective yeah i like
that list so i guess
before we sort of start unpacking your
career what what came up for me when you
shared that
your first point because i think that's
something that sometimes
people early on in their recruitment
career really have to work through
yeah how how positive was rachel at the
beginning of her recruitment career
how much of a piece of market did you
have i mean
i i'm not that great at talking about
myself it's more
how people describe me and i think yeah
correct me if i'm wrong anyone that's
listening that knows me but
um i've said i've always been a very
positive disposition
um obviously where did that come from
knox but i mean you've known me for a
couple of years i think yeah
i mean i would say i'm naturally quite
positive so i'd say that when i first
started i was i was just as positive as
i am today
yeah well i guess the reason why i said
i'm interested to like
like where that came from was it that
you surround your family and friends
were positive was it
that's just like you thought well what's
the alternative i don't know anything
interesting do you know what that's
really it's a really interesting
question
and i've got no idea i think i mean my
mum i look at her
she's a very positive person the people
i surround myself with
are very positive people and i think you
sometimes you
you just have that that mindset and i
don't think you often know
where you've got it from but i've been
fortunate that i do have it and
and i can tell negativity i can really
feel if someone's being negative to me
or if someone is quite negative person i
just
um i i i shy away from that really i
i can't really get my head around it
love that
okay interesting so
let's obviously you you've worked in
industry for sort of some time now
obviously straight out of universities
so i guess
what i'm always interested in here
because it's typically the most
challenging
parts of um someone's career
particularly recruitment but like how
how would you describe first-year
recruitment
early days like how would you just
describe that experience
wow well the first in recruitment is so
so fun well
in back when you go to pubs and go out
and meet people
um yes you piss learning curve it's
definitely the hardest year
i've been in recruitment 11 years now
and the first year
is always going to be your hardest and
it's such a steep learning curve
you're joining an industry that you
don't know anything about like i don't
even know the difference between
contract and permanent i don't really
know what recruitment was when i first
joined
so you have to learn the industry and
then
uh learn your vertical market or
whatever it is so
um whatever skill sets they are
and then within whatever sector there's
so much and then learning how to close
people
learning the candidate management side
there's so much information
um and wanting to get that promotion um
i just remember
constantly being in competition with my
peers
um there were four of us who were hired
we were all grads um all very similar
level i guess in terms of
our cv um or academic background
um and i think we were just all it was
healthy competition we just all wanted
to do the next deal we all wanted to get
promoted first
um so it was really um full-on
but um highly competitive but in a good
way
um and actually really enjoyable
you did feel like you've got that city
job as cringing as that sounds but you
know you're out a lot
you meet a lot of new people going to
nice restaurants going tonight's past
but then also you're working really hard
you know you're working the longer hours
so it was very
high octane i'd probably describe as um
okay and then just to frame out because
so you joined
rulian and yeah like as at the time how
how big was that business because it's
it's quite a big business isn't it from
what i understand i didn't
i didn't actually realize how big rulian
wasn't i laughed so
um because i joined um tom breese and
andrew shaw who
at now french has found us um at the end
of 2009 i just graduated i was the
first one they actually hired in because
it was just the two of them they were
setting up the london office
so even though ruling has this big
presence up in the north
in london not many people have heard of
them and obviously i was
the first into the office barring tom
and andy
so it was kind of like a startup but
with the background of
even though rouleon wasn't um
massively well known in the south
compared to our some of our competitors
like aston carter
and you know like various others so i
didn't realize how big william was
because to me it was just as in that
office
yeah yeah that makes sense okay that's
really interesting
everyone knows who they are so yeah
so i guess so you spoke a bit about that
first year i guess
if i say to you what were some of the
sort of biggest challenges that you
maybe had to overcome in that first year
what what comes up for you do you think
what were some of the things you had to
really push for in that first year um
i don't think i was naturally the best
closer
of candidates okay in all honesty um i
had to learn
a lot from um tom and andy when it came
to that because i had some
when i first hit my promotion um i had a
couple of
um offers and i couldn't close either of
them and i was absolutely gutted because
i've just been promoted i'd have been
paid on the
full commission scheme i'd got the
client on or whatever it was the process
but i couldn't close them and now i'm
like god rachel what an idiot like it's
you don't have that
it's like if you've done things
differently so i actually struggled with
that
but um now i absolutely love it like i
love having those conversations
thrive on it so that's something that i
was i was really scared to have those
conversations back then but once i
understood what's more comfortable with
that yeah
yeah so i said that was probably my my
biggest challenge
starting out really interesting so i
guess
in that then what again thinking about
and it doesn't have to be particularly
your first year but
sort of sort of focusing on the theme of
light early on in your career what
what was maybe sort of the best piece of
advice that you received early on
in your recruit do you think under
promise over deliver
nice yeah 100 and that goes for
everything in life i
i find
that's so important
okay i mean there is there's a lot of
loads of lots of advice i've received
and lots of
sayings that really sum things up um but
that's probably
the main the main thing yeah yeah yeah
got that
so just to sort of frame it up for
people for context so when you
enter the industry and like where you
are now have you because
are you um have you always typically
been in contract or has it been like a
dual desk or like just give me a bit of
context and that for people listening
and
can help help that well so when we
started out we're predominantly
permanent business
um but um and
then um once i started building my
vertical out
um so towards the end of 2010
um we were able to work both contract
and permanent roles because
you know if you're building a vertical
market like you should be able to
service both
otherwise you're giving off your
business to someone else so
um rudolph is really good with that if
you run your own business then you can
work both the contract and the perm
roles
um so i was trained initially doing
permanent but then
as i uh started to be a consultant doing
new business i did
contract as well and then since then
i've been doing both um
when i joined venture in 2017 i was
director of contracts um yeah but
then since then obviously with the
market changing
due to ir35 and various other things um
i now work across both again so i
started perm did both then went contract
and now we're doing both
okay that's that's really honestly from
the amount of conversations i had i've
had
i would definitely wouldn't say that's
like typical like obviously i'm sure
so i don't so i guess interested to
dig into that i guess the thing that
came up to me i really like the way that
you put that well
like why you're potentially giving away
50 of your business
right or 50 of things so i guess
what the question that came up for me
straight away and you can sort of draw
on any part of your career on this but
like
let's say like how have you become like
what have you had to become better at to
make sure that
your end client your end customer knows
that rachel can support them not only on
the
permanent vacancies but also on contract
um
so i think it's like i don't know let's
say that you've always supported me on a
permanent basis
how have you then made sure that you've
maximized the opportunity to make sure
that they know that at some point or
they know that you can also support on
the contract side like how have you
always made sure that you
covered buyers good both good question
um
so typically you win contract business
via
working well with the client on the
permanent side
because naturally well more often than
not permanent roles are hard to fill
them contract roles unless you're
talking very niche
technologies but on the whole so it's
quite difficult to win new contract
business
but it's slightly easier to win new
permanent businesses what i've found
so you do a good job on the permanent
side and then your client will
off more often than not give you
contract roles to work on as well
there are times when clients haven't
even realized that i've worked contracts
and that's something that happened early
on so i've always been
really i've always made sure that i've
let them know
all of our service lines um because
obviously there's other things like the
retained search piece as well so
um i've always been aware that it's
really important to get a meeting with
the client and explain
exactly what your service lines are so
and and then if there's any doubt
i would always ask the question oh so
now we filled this permanent role for
you
who looks do you hire contractors um how
many contractors do you have on the site
how how do you onboard them and just
have those conversations
there is nothing wrong with asking that
you are a business person and you're
here to provide solutions so
so you should be able to to provide them
with both
yeah both i love that and i think the
the key part there is that you've got
like it's about ask
if you're asking the question when
we're in the sort of positive dynamic
aren't we where you might have played
someone that i've been looking for
and we're having that conversation
whilst you've just delivered for me
you know i mean you're asking that
question yeah and
there's been so many times where i've
had fixed term contracts which i know
are rife in the market at the moment
with r35
and i flipped them and said look would
you consider a day rate contractor
this is what you could get if you had
this budget
and more often not like wow this is the
level
yeah sure let's get them in for three
months and see how it goes rather than
committing to say a nine month ftc
so you can flip them like that um so i
think it's always really important to
be really clear with with the solutions
you can
provide because we are a solutions
provider we're not just um
you know send me a requirement and i'll
fill it we have to offer
extra i think
yeah no i love that that's really great
so i guess just focus on this for a
second because i think it's interesting
like if i'm listening right now and i
don't know maybe in my
in my business there's separate teams
people that just do permanent some
people just do contract right yeah
i guess how would you just like if
someone would be open to potentially
doing both or at least making sure
they're asking the question getting
those opportunities where they then
could pass it on to people that could
fill it but that could then mean they
could get a share of the commission or
whatever right
just maximize the opportunities they
have in their market
how would you what would you say like
maybe the top three things that you need
to master that
a bit different to being a permanent
focus recruiter
if we're then sort of going down the
path of providing our clients with
contract talent fixed term contract what
are the sort of key things that you need
to become really good at that may be
slightly different
to the permanent side okay um
speed of delivery number one i mean you
can't be
i have i set myself a deadline whenever
i get a contract role to have it
delivered within 24 hours no matter what
um people minimum um with permanent you
obviously there are less people
typically
you can have maybe a week or so to go
out do your linkedin headhunting
however you do it but with contract
speed is so important i've seen a lot of
people who have tried to contract but
they're just not quick enough
um so i think just being really astute
with that like look i've got
you even if they don't give you a
deadline you say to them
you will have three of the best
candidates by closing business on x day
which should be 24 hours and you just
have to to get it delivered because if
you don't then someone else will
um urgency emergency speed
yep um number two
this you're gonna have a lot of response
whether it's ad
advert or if if you're searching head
hunting
um typically at the moment as well there
aren't that many contracts out there
so you have to be able to separate the
wheat from the chaff
so looking at hundreds of cvs for like a
business analyst for example
all the cvs look the same how am i going
to differentiate so i think you have to
be
to know your market well enough to be
able to tell which
person is better than the other so i
guess like market knowledge
and being able to identify the best out
of a
big but like um a big do these if that
makes sense
so i don't know how you sum that up in
one word
that's okay no i i guess what you're
saying there is yeah you have to get
you be expect maybe a lot more interest
than you would maybe
a permanent position and there's going
to be potential a lot more people in the
market
so like you have to again it's speed
isn't it you have to get really
professional and speedy at
what do i what is it that i know i need
to look for
and what are the sort of minimum
requirements and and get really good at
that so that makes sense yeah and i
think that ties itself into time
management
as well you need to dedicate time right
i'm gonna dedicate this
this afternoon to getting three of the
best candidates i'm gonna make sure that
i've covered
all different angles off to make sure
that i've got the best person rather
than my competitors so it's really about
managing your diary effectively
um and just being quite ruthless
sometimes if you're not quite sure about
someone not maybe not right cultural
personality there are so many other
people with similar skill sets so
knowing your clients well it really
helps too because you'll see oh they've
worked at x company i know they love
people from x company
that person's going to the top of my
pile so it's just being quite a student
um yeah there's no reason why you can't
be good at permanent and good contract i
think people that think they're one or
the other i mean
that could be the case but i don't see
any reason why i couldn't be good at
both
yeah absolutely and then you're yeah
obviously living testament of that so i
guess
because because you've touched on it
let's go into it but
one of the most popular sort of
questions and there is that people
really interested in rachel
is time management is how did rachel
sort of early on in her career structure
her day to like how she now structures
her day do you know what i mean
so just because you mentioned one of
those really important tips being time
management is clearly
you've been doing this for 11 years now
right so it's something that you
probably had to
get really good at yeah so i guess
so i'm like let me ask that question to
you then if
it's okay with you because people want
to know basically like
what did rachel do when how did rachel
structure her days
when she was billing i don't know 100
150 200k just maybe early on in our
recruitment career to then
when you was billing double that or
whatever what did you change in a day
what
what became non-negotiable and stuff
like that so i guess how
how does your day look now compared to
how it looked
early on in your critique thing that you
had to refine and get better at
it's a difficult one because the
obviously every day
is is different you know something could
happen
that takes you you could have a dropout
it's meant to start on that morning
and you have to like rework it you know
i wouldn't i don't get too hung up on
like every day i do this
religiously it doesn't work like that in
recruitment
in my opinion i know the people so i
when it comes to week i always make sure
i have time for business development
whether it's now or back then i think no
matter what level you're at
you always need to have your eye on the
next client and the next new
client so i'll dedicate i mean
most days i didn't dedicate at least
two hours i'd say to business
development
yeah obviously there are urgent roles
that need delivering
so the usual put the job up the night
before
go through your response do your
linkedin project the night before as
well come in and do your call backs all
pretty standard stuff
um and then you don't you may have
client calls as well
but every morning what i do i get up
i would say i'll start work these days
say about eight o'clock
would i call at nine o'clock but i'd
have my to-do list written down for the
day
um sometimes i'd do it the night before
it really depends
so i keep structured to that obviously
keep ticking it off but as we know
things can happen during that day and
kind of keep you off and like drag you
off course but
i just keep my list and i keep making
sure that i do everything on that list
before i
leave leave the office so it's not
there's no magic
way to structure a day i don't think
because i think everyone's
everyone's like clients are different
everyone's industries are different or
how they work but
keeping that making sure you're getting
good candidates out make sure your
clients are happy
and then looking for the next new
business opportunity
the most important things no i love that
and i think what
what i find interesting about that which
i think comes up time and time again
with
more experienced recruiters is always
making space
for that new business time for that
business development
because i think early on you can get a
bit complacent with that can't you yeah
right
but i've got these jobs on now i'm in
the press feeling i'm just going to
focus on that
and then all of a sudden you get towards
the end of the month you know oh my god
i filled with these jobs now i need to
restart that and get onto the new new
business focus again right
yeah so many times so people have
got so bogged down and what they're
delivering or managing accounts and
stuff and then suddenly
they fill those roles there's nothing
else in the pipeline so it's really
important to keep it consistent then you
feel like you're feeling
like it's going up an uphill battle then
and then you might be going you're just
making it difficult for yourself aren't
you
i guess yeah i think to be a consequence
you kind of have to keep consistently
doing the business development i think
that is it's as simple as that
yeah so let's just i was going to ask
you about
sort of do you sort of set goals and
stuff like that because that's a really
popular error but let me
because again we've gone into new
business right like that
like client development is like
the most popular development area for
recruiters it is
every time yeah is it this new business
or existing
accounts new business new business yeah
but i want to go over that with you
because i know from the context that i
have you've been good at
expanding accounts as well we it's all
it's very easy to go straight to
like new business but i think it's
sometimes
there's a lot of missed opportunities in
terms of expanding accounts like
instead of just doing spot business
right so
um i guess because you've spoken about
it let's just talk about
um again you can draw on different parts
of your career but let's just talk about
your journey
with new business right so it's
something that you
always make time for in your weeks
because as we just said
that sort of really helps you be a con
become more of a consistent builder
so i guess the first question i have for
you and you can maybe say a couple of
things but what comes up for you but
like what has been like the most
effective and reliable way for rachel to
win new business
like throughout your career it doesn't
have to be one thing but like what what
things have just been the most effective
and reliable way for you to continue to
win new business and
ensure keeping that pipeline filled
yeah i think having a obviously a
vertical market so market specialism i
think is key
so when i first started i had um
something called lean and six sigma
which is a process improvement
method methodology which is really big
um
when i joined recruitment because it was
the term what was the financial crisis
and a lot of the banks will want to make
our savings
i'm not going too much detail of that
but um so ever since i started i had a
vertical
and the more and more i spoke to people
about it i pulled my leads
and i kept getting the same names i was
like i'm gonna win this account
um and i'll just keep going sen and i
knew i knew exactly what they wanted
because i qualified
the leads perfectly and i have someone
that i knew was perfect i know as soon
as this
client sees a cv we'll get an interview
and that's exactly what happened
so um it was that really good market
intelligence
being like fervent whether you know just
persistently
every day going through the job boards
who else has come on um
speaking to people basically and getting
that market information
and then sending them the ideal
candidate so it has been
i guess specking out as we call it but
from that i've grown accounts and i've
kept clients from that approach that
have worked with me for
years and years now so that's what i
found the most effective
um hot leads getting as much information
specking in someone who is perfect and
and then going from there
of course it doesn't work every time
back in 2009 it may have been a bit a
bit easier than it is now
because we had switchboards as well that
we could call the clients up and sell
the candidates in
but when i look back at the and even to
this day an account i won
a couple of weeks ago it was it was
within that vertical i saw they were
hiring i knew it'd be a tough hire
because the salary
i called them up said i'm a specialist
in this area i think we've actually
spoken about roles before
when you're looking and then and then
they're like right well
let's let's give you a go you you
clearly know what you're talking about
so
knowing your market inside out
and approaching people in the right way
in this targeted
and concise way that's what i found
works
it's just consistently right yeah okay
yeah interesting
sorry i was gonna say no you have what
you know the client wants
then they don't care what agency they
pay they're already paying
an agency fee but you just have to tempt
them with that and then it kind of goes
from there
yeah yeah i'll go you say yeah really
double down on your market knowledge
and intelligence and i think just in
your opinion because i think sometimes
people can
get that mistreat as if like they
like people listening to this have to
like be as competent as the people they
place
like in their job but like all the
people i speak to isn't that it's
actually
the intelligence intelligent
intelligence of knowing who's doing what
what company's grown what company isn't
growing where the opportunities are so
when you say like really double down on
your market intelligence like what what
do you exactly mean by that
just to sort of make that really clear
for people where can people really
double down
knowing who's who's hiring as you say
knowing exactly what they're looking for
um and being able to have a good
conversation with the client about
it i know this is like like
understanding their pain points
saying look would you be open to to
reviewing this cv i've worked with ax
compass sir
i know that you're doing something
really similar they've got great
references and just really selling the
candidate but knowing about your market
knowing about the skill set and and what
that client pain point is
like wow like this person really doesn't
know what they're talking about they're
not just a sales person
trying to trying to get and get money
about
money out of them we're actually trying
to solve their problem because as we
know in recruitment
on contingency it's you know no win no
fees they're not paying us anything
until
until they they make that offer so it's
just about being really consultative and
that and
and knowing what you're talking about
and there's a lot of people that say oh
you know i don't really understand my
vertical i've only been in it six months
it's like
you need to understand it like do
whatever you need to do like read books
speak to
as many people within the industry as
possible you can't make excuses
like if you're giving a mark you should
know it inside out
as as soon as you can because it because
if you don't then
then you won't sound credible and you
won't win the business
yeah okay so let's let's transition this
then
to something that clearly you've done
really well in your career
as well because you just mentioned it as
in like you've that's how you may have
that's been a really consistent way of
you winning business yeah and how
how has then rachel become really good
at making sure that
we're then building actually long-term
client relationships and we're building
clients for for the long run
and so i guess how have you gone about
one
making sure that you're building
long-term relationships
with clients so then it's not just okay
yeah we gave rachel a chance she placed
it
that was great cool that that that's
that and done
um and then the other part of the
question the second part of the question
is then
how have you become good at going
taking a good client that's spending x
to a great client that's spending double
that or triple that
well that's quite a big question really
i'll try to um
address it from um from my experience
so in terms of developing long-term
relationships the number one thing
is via delivery if you deliver them
the best candidates then then they'll
come back to you
and i mean adventure as a whole and
and something that i believe for like i
really believe in
is developing these long-term
relationships i'm not interested in
coming in doing one deal charging a high
rate and then walking off it's like
the hardest thing is opening the
business in the first place in my
opinion
why would you then walk away you want to
maximize that as much as you can
so what i would do in the normal world i
go out have a meeting with them
maybe go for a lunch go for a drink
coffee whatever
it is um get to know them more on that
kind of personal level
and then say look is there anyone who
you'd recommend that i could speak to in
the business
and you'd be surprised how many people
say actually i know my colleagues
looking for this
do you guys do this oh yes that's not my
area but
x person um is like is an expert in say
developer roles yeah so again it's by
asking the question
it's always better doing it on a
face-to-face because people
give away a lot more when you're with
them face to face
they're awkward if they say oh no like
you can't wear with me anymore
so that that's really important when
things go back to normal i can't wait to
go meet my clients again i just think
that
it will help me develop my current
clients even more um so asking that
question
would you be happy to sponsor me over to
this colleague would you be able to
see me um most of my relationships in
fact i was looking through this
morning all my roles are on exclusive
so what i would say i've done a good job
if you've been wanted for this role for
x
amount of months would you be happy to
work with me exclusively
moving forwards this means i'll be able
to be more dedicated
delivery team etc etc so it's about
asking the questions
and if you've done a good job there's no
reason why they wouldn't want to
introduce you to their colleagues well
they wouldn't want to give it to you an
exclusive
and my best client is someone that i
spec candidate into on my first day as a
consultant it was so fluky
but she's actually a really good friend
of mine as well and she's she's hooked
up at four different clients since that
first thing
when i was 21 back in 2009 so
yeah meeting people a lot keeping in
contact
and letting them know that you you are
still here you're still available and
you want to work with them more
i love it i know i know you may think oh
it sounds like quite basic and simple
but i think it's just so important for
people to hear
like how like the most important thing
is that you're delivering that you're
providing a great level of service and
you can that needs to be your standard
because if you really focus on that then
the opportunities long term as you just
mentioned are huge
and then it's about what clearly you've
probably had to become better at is
making sure you're asking questions like
okay well i've done a good job here
let's let's talk about me being
exclusive on the next role and this is
the reason
why or hey you know i've done a good job
here can
is there anyone else that i can speak to
so it seems like you've got better
asking the question but it all stems
from
rachel someone that delivers rachel
someone that has really provided for us
and then
that's what gives you the opportunities
definitely
and there's nothing wrong with asking
these questions what's the worst that
can happen they say oh no sorry we have
to use this other agency
okay no problem well i'm confident that
you know i will continue to fill these
roles and then guess what in six months
time they'll
actually i think we're just gonna use
you now so you know you have to prove
yourself of course
um but if you've done a good job there's
absolutely no harm and
i find account development so much
easier than
new client um development
or getting the term signed to getting
the first one in is so much harder
than developing the client yeah
okay love it so
just for context when when did you start
sort of um managing or leading people
being responsible for other people
oh gosh quite early on i think um
it must have been within my second year
at rouleon
i'd say oh wow okay um so
it's always been very meritocratic in
that if you win clients and if you have
enough work on you'll get
someone to come and help you resource so
from very early on i've always had
someone who who was able to support me
on the delivery side
yeah because from the company's
perspective would free me up to win new
clients so
yeah yeah i've always had a resource
from from quite a young a young age
really
yeah sure and i think correct me if i'm
wrong obviously with ventura now is it a
bit of a similar
like obviously we mentioned in an
introduction that you're responsible for
supporting
a delivery team so i guess just just
interested to hear your thoughts really
on
because i think there's companies that
obviously got 360 and different
different models right but i guess
why do you feel having a sort of hybrid
delivery model
is a good one so where ie yeah like you
just said maybe rachel you spend a lot
of time
developing existing and new new clients
and then you've got obviously recruiters
that might be early on in their career
who maybe start building their networks
and communities in the candidate side
and then build yeah start building
confidence and get good at
getting them leads from candidates and
going into clients but they're also
supporting you and getting that
experience i don't know what
why do you think that's a potential good
model and how why do you think it works
so that's a new kind of model that we've
adopted um after recently
um it's kind of like um a hybrid model
so it's where we bring people in you've
got maybe six months or so of experience
on the delivery on the resourcing side
so
pretty strong on that side um and
we can bring them in on their they'll
have two separate commission plans
so you'd have the delivery so the
resourcing i guess
um commission scheme um but then you'd
also have your new business
scheme which is obviously um a lot more
rewarding so without
giving people bringing hiring people
saying look you have to do new business
you're going to get no support
we wanted to get people so to get up and
running doing their resourcing deals
they're having some money coming in
because i appreciate how important
many years especially at that stage in
your
in your career but then we're also
saying look we can help develop you on
the business development side of things
and you will be rewarded you know if you
any new client you bring in it will be
yours like for as long as you're
eventually four
and also i'm more than happy to help
open those clients up
for them as well um as a director i'm
not paid on individual
billing so it doesn't matter to me
whether or not it's my client or it's my
my my delivery consultant so that's
great in a way that means that we can
all work together and help the company
grow as well
so it's that hybrid model of doing the
resourcing side
get getting that money coming in quite
early but then also being able to do the
business development side but not just
being thrown in the deep end and like
sink or swim which i know a lot of
companies still
do for some god most reason yeah got it
but but it's working well so far
so what what just why do you think that
that's
i don't know why have you gone down that
route for out of interest
um i think bringing people on with a bit
of experience is
quite um obvious because we're working
from home
and right now and it's just knowing that
people know the basics
is it's it's so much easier to get them
up to speed um
when we return to the office who knows
it may change but this is how
it's working for us right now um and
i think it works really well because
people can be really
taking that step into business
development is the most daunting
scary period of your recruitment career
i know i've been through it
um this is such a softer landing because
of course we'd love people to come in
and win loads and you can't straight
away but reality is
most people don't don't do that so
it's it works because you're not
alienating people or people aren't
getting upset because not doing any
deals you're keeping that momentum and
they are adding to the business
they are adding value to the business
and then also
if they want to go out there and pull
their own needs and chase their own
leads there is that
scheme available and there is support
available so it means that people
can progress at their own rate um and
not necessarily beating them with a
stick to to open new clients which
often leads to very like toxic work
culture and
as essentially people leaving so um i
can't speak on their behalf but i think
that
the people we've had recently are really
enjoying the model
and um and and hopefully it continues
yeah nice yeah
i think the sort of key thing that you
said there is that sort of soft landing
because i went through that and it is
it can be daunting you built up business
development in your head
it's like not something that you've got
used to and then yeah it can be
a challenging transition so that that
makes sense so i guess
what i was just keen to um talk a bit
about then
was yeah your journey with leadership
your journey with communicating with
people from a
team perspective getting the most out of
your team and stuff like that so i guess
i guess the first thing like what
along your journey what have been some
of the sort of challenges or hurdles
because
a lot of the time people will say that
sort of being in that billing manager
role or just
being in a role where you're building it
managing your own performance and
managing other people's performance
is one of the most difficult roles in
recruitment and typically
like you how like typically a lot of
people that end up in that role may not
have any form of leadership training
yeah or anything like that so they have
to sort of learn on the job and
go through these sort of challenges so i
guess what
what have been some of the things that
you've had to work through which you've
had to become better at in terms of
things that you may have found more
difficult early on in your
leadership career when you had to
monitor other people's performance yeah
there's been a few things really
um i think when i first i mean i always
had a resource
as i mentioned but not necessarily
billing
um consultant so with the resources it
was kind of quite easy to manage because
i'd just you know give them the jobs
i'll go do my bd happy days
when it becomes like more billing you
look after billing consultants
you're not an individual biller anymore
and i think that's the hardest thing to
get over
before ourselves i was billing how much
i've made the company how many clients
and now you have to shift it's like no
race it's not about you it's about the
company
and it's about that being more more
selfless
and being like actually hang on it's not
about being top biller it's about
us billing an amount for the company and
for everyone
to be doing really well because there is
nothing better than
a team where everyone's smashing their
targets it's just such a good
environment and that's when
recruitment's at its best
so i think initially that was my problem
um but then i i soon got over that and
and i saw the benefit um and
something what was the benefit just
equipment on that sir because i think
that's probably the most common thing is
yeah not just
not just waking up every day and going
right how much am i going to build this
month or
am i closer to target but as you said
become more selfless
so what what did you have to tap into or
what made
when you did sort of tap into that what
made it worth it where did you get maybe
your buzz from or what
where was you surprised that actually
you got a lot of enjoyment out of
i realized that other people doing well
because of how i've
helped them and train them is actually
more rewarding than than myself
and that's a mindset thing i think as
you get older as well
you actually have um you know watching
some like your first
someone open the first client themselves
um
is such a great feeling because then you
say look i've told you like you can do
it
and they're so happy and you just get
excited for that
rather than it being yourself it's
someone else and you like i've
i feel like i need to import part on to
other people i'd just be selfish if i
was just to
concentrate on myself and focus on my
own development watching other people
be prove themselves wrong you know you
have ups and downs you have times in the
meeting room where like i can't do it i
can't do it i'm not going to build i'm
not going to
target then when they do it i'm like
look you can you can do it and it just
shows that
the if you can make other people
successful then
it is the best feeling and you also know
that you're not completely useless as
well
if the other people doing well
you know it is it is a beast for
yourself
um definitely and and as i said
there there is no better feeling than
when everyone smashing it
um you know i love that it's the typical
recruitment thing
go out for lunch early on a thursday or
friday don't go back to the office
you know um that is a big reason of why
joint recruitment was for those
for those moments so i think it's yeah
i think it's great when you contribute
to that
some something you just mentioned there
which is a really popular question that
i get is like
what you just said there around people
going look rachel i can't do it i'm
finding it difficult i'm doubting myself
i guess sort of people and then
particularly managers or people going on
early on on that leadership sort of
journey have to
i think that's something they have to
deal with quite quickly where they will
have people in their team doubting
themselves and not have that confidence
so i guess
the question is is like in those moments
how how have you got better at what
where do you typically go to help them
carry on or help them
start believing themselves or make them
feel like
they can do it even though they're
doubting themselves
i think you have to leave lead from the
front
um and i think you have to like
understand the situation and explain why
it's happened
and you have to flip i always say this
flip negative in
like into a positive if people are
getting down on themselves they'll say
well last year
you you um you did x y and z like
everyone has blips no one's consistent
not every quarter is going to be amazing
for everyone for every
and every year it's just not going to
happen so you
i bring them back to times when things
did go well
and i'll say look what do you do then
how are you doing it differently now
like we need to get back to that to that
mindset
what's gone wrong is actually you could
control or is that life
has this deal dropped out because that
sometimes happens it's just about
dissecting exactly the situation
and then saying like look it's not it
might not even be their fault you know
it's it's just a bad run of luck which
we know can happen um it's just being
positive
making people realize that it's just a
you know formless
temporary class is permanent i do really
believe that
we'll have times and i say look i'll
i'll draw back on examples when it's
happened to me
in my past just to show that like there
is
there is light at the end of the tunnel
yeah no i love that
and let's let's talk about that for a
second because i think
like clearly you're someone that does
have a positive mindset and outlook
um and yeah it sounds like you're
helping people
along with your career start sort of
seeing the positive and stuff like that
but i guess
what what have been i mean the question
that sometimes i get and
you can this could be a question to
frame up doesn't have to be that you've
experienced this but basically people
want to know
like what's the question is like what's
the longest you blanked and how did you
recover
so people want to know like what have
been the darkest days and how did you
like
get back on the to get to those highs
and recruitments you know what i mean so
feel free to answer the longest time you
did blank and then how did you recover
or
just sort of draw on an experience where
like you know what i really had to pick
myself back up there and how did you do
that
okay well i mean i'm a positive person
obviously there are days
and times when i get very racist so i
don't even think i
know you feel positive all the time
because things do happen
um in terms of blank there's never been
a massive maybe a
two months which actually is actually
quite a long time
um if you didn't come back um so um i
can't remember what year it was i think
i
think it might have been the end of my
second year
or third year but um it happens to
everyone
um there even now there are months where
i don't contribute as much as the other
directors do
i mean i think in like january for
example i think i did
like a couple of deals the rest of guys
in six or seven um
brought it back this month um so we're
on a level playing field now but
it still happens and um
thinking back of a time where i hit hit
my my lowest
low um was my second year
it was a new business deal um with with
rbs i mean i'd say the client because i
don't work with them anymore but
i'm obviously thank you client when
expect someone into senior role it would
end up being the
30 grand deal the guy accepted
signed his contract i was oh my god the
30 grand and he was a steal my
first year as a consultant second year
in recruitment wow everyone's like oh my
god rachel's amazing and then
the guy called me like the friday before
and said i've been counter-offered three
different jobs at
x place where he was um
i'm gonna have to take it and i was like
oh my god
and i remember crying when i got home
and it takes quite a lot to make me cry
but
that that wasn't i said i just can't do
it
i i'd like i can't do recruitment
anymore
yeah yeah and now i look back and i was
like oh my god like i was
20 22 now i've done a 30 grand new
business deal my first year like now i'm
thinking like
to get it to that point i should be
positive okay it didn't go over
i didn't get my big payout but i can
look
back on that now so if anyone's going
through similar things like that
just be happy that you got to that point
and you know if it if it goes in amazing
but if it doesn't don't be too hard on
yourself
because you because only you have got
that to that point
for that particular i love that yeah i
love that so it's changing the focus on
not it's changing the focus on the
outcome and actually the focus on the
process and the journey to get to that
point is something that
well actually i've done really well
there this is what i've learned this is
what i've done well
like okay it didn't go my way this time
but that's actually a great achievement
yeah it will go in and it's like
and i've always the junior guys you
think about what can i add to the
business
um was there anyone else who could have
made that 30 grand with that
at that point in time it's like no there
wasn't because there wasn't anyone else
at that point
so you have to think this is what i like
we wouldn't even have this opportunity
if it wasn't for me and i know that's
very kind of like
um being quite boastful but you have to
believe in yourself
in recruitment because if you don't and
the negative thoughts come in they will
take over you so you have to
back yourself um but also self-awareness
i think it is
it's an important balance yeah i love
that
so i have to before we before we finish
i have to i wanted to definitely go over
this with you
so women in recruitment
right let's just let's just talk about
this right yeah so
obviously you entered the recruitment
industry at yeah
an early age um you need these types of
things
so i guess there's a few things that um
i'll be interested to ask you but
whenever i've
sort of had uh women in recruitment on
this podcast what typically seems to
happen is that like as rachel goes
through her career there's
not as many women to look up to and go
wow i want to get to that director's
spot or where that
woman is i want to get to right whereas
for maybe like me for example
i could join the industry and there'll
be loads of men to look and go wow i
want to replicate what they've done
right yeah so i guess the the question
is is
one how have you found being a female
recruitment and carvering out your
journey in
in the recruitment industry how one have
you found that and then two
like from that experience like how do
you feel that we can get more
females one into the industry but two
into positions like yourself where
you're now a director at a business
you're involved in actually growing the
business not just putting numbers on the
boards
so yeah one how's your experience and
journey been and two
how do you think we can actually move
the the needle and impact
more female to get more female role
models in in the industry
um i've always worked in a really male
dominated environment
um so strangely i i kind of feel used to
it and
it's really bad because um it shouldn't
be as male dominated as it is and i
would love to empower
other women because i think that women
have so much
especially in a boardroom and uh you
know that emotional intelligence
and um how have i found it
i mean i've always been surrounded by a
lot of men so you kind of adapt i think
it is
and um i've been lucky like my bosses
have always been very
fair you know it's never been a gender
thing
and in some ways it's kind of helped my
career be being a woman because
when you're in a minority
out more so when i'm pitching people
when i first started out i was
more than a female most the guys are
southern
or the southern men so it already made
me stand out
and um my best clients
are all well all the randomly majority
are women from scotland and i don't know
whether that's because it was refreshing
for them to have a northern lady
or maybe i'm reading yeah yeah but and
we get on really well now you know you
still go out for drinks
so i think it actually benefited me
because i
was different to other people um
other recruiters out there so you took a
positive
disposition on it again instead of
viewing it as a disadvantage used
actually as an advantage yeah definitely
i think
sometimes it's better to be in the
minority for some things because it
means that you can
that you are different and um i don't
know whether it was that
having a female for some people it might
be more comforting or trusting or
whatever it is i don't know but i
actually
quite enjoyed that and um
the more you move upwards is that this
hardly
i couldn't say a woman um it might
in my uh vertical market at the same
level
as me that i've ever been on a psl with
or met
for a client meeting or anyone like that
and they've
they've all been men and it's just
that you kind of accept but thinking
about it
it is strange and it is something that
i'd like i don't understand why because
the female recruiters you have in our
team they're all great
um i don't understand why it is so male
dominated to be honest with you
yeah is yeah no idea but i think the
important thing is
is that we're talking about you know and
there's conversation as to why is this
what
what can companies what can guys do more
to make it more inclusive make it more
welcoming for
um females so i guess what i don't know
what do you have any thoughts on like
how can we encourage more sort of women
and diverse
um people into the recruitment industry
i don't know if it's about encouraging
them into the industry i think it's
about sustaining them and making sure
they stay within the industry and don't
need them
yeah like our intake recently has been
very female dominated um and we don't
judge on gender it's just the best
person to get the job and it's just so
happened
that throughout the four of them have
been women
so why are they coming in at this level
why and why but why are they not
filtering up to the top i think that's
my
my main question is the fact that
there's men men at the top that
don't have don't understand how to
communicate with women as well
know how to i mean not in my case
obviously because i'm where i am but
within other companies
is it a bit of a boys club are women not
viewed as
equals in some way or they commented
about in the office there's
so many things is it the work culture
that drives them out
is it the job that drives them out is it
lack of support is it lack of female
role models
that's the big question for me is why do
we have so many people coming to entry
and then they don't progress upwards
yeah yeah that's a really great point
so i guess who who was your role model
then did you have a role model like how
how do you feel how do you feel like you
said there that you sort of
actually like embraced that you're in
the minority and that's something that
you tried to
use in a positive way but who was your
ronaldo and how did you make sure that
you
sustained your career and pushed through
and and got to where you wanted to
um i'm not very big on role models
um i think there are people in this life
that
you meet that you're inspired by and you
want
proud and you want to strive to do the
best for them
there isn't one particular person i was
in or of i wanted to progress up was
maybe because there wasn't any women at
that level
perhaps but i've been inspired by a lot
of individuals and
obviously um my my current bosses tom
and andy
have obviously been there throughout my
career they're the ones that have
spurred me on you know i want to do deal
to make them proud
i want to do well to make them proud i
want to prove to them that i'm
the best at what i do so i think it's
been more
um taking in inspiration
from people more senior than me and
wanting to do the best
to make them proud of me obviously um
money is i'm a motivator but for me it's
about doing a good job
and across ventures about us doing a
good job for our clients
and being the best we can be and then
the rest kind of comes comes along with
it
um so no particular role model but there
are people who have inspired me along
the way
of course love that okay
i've got five final questions for you
okay
go for it okay yeah so
first one if if you could change the
industry
what would you improve um
i don't think this is answering the
question but what i would like to change
is people's perception of the
recruitment industry
um so i'm not sure this answer the
question
exactly but i think we get a lot of
stick i don't think people realize what
we do in the background
sometimes to get these deals in um to
get candidates to start
um so i i think we've got very negative
i think we still do
people have very like i see post on
linkedin i saw one today and i wanted to
write something and obviously
um but i think i'd like to change the
way the industry
is viewed from an external perspective
because i think
there's a lot of good recruiters out
there and i think that people don't
realize exactly the stress
we go through to make sure people get
get the job so i'd like to change the
perception on recruitment
i love that um second question
best ever day in recruitment describe it
do you remember it uh
just about remember it um
it was i think it was 2018. the sun was
shining
um we'd had a good month but one of
those weeks when we thought the deals
were going to come in and they hadn't so
it was
friday lunchtime and then um
uh andy said like let's let's let's go
out for lunch
like we've had a good good month let's
go and just go and chill out um really
nice day went out to our favorite tapas
bar
in borough market sat out there having
glass of rose
um living the life and then suddenly all
these deals came in
and someone was happy or two so it was
about the laptop
out we four of us working on one laptop
people going down the streets to
pose i think we must have done about um
10 or 12 deals
just sat out there and you know closing
deals whilst
whilst eating europa potatoes brahmas
it was just one of those great days
where you look back on and think do you
know what when recruitment's good
it's the best job ever um
and days like that help you get through
the bad days we all have bad days
it's about resilience and remembering
those those good times but
that was a particularly enjoyable day
fun memory yeah love that um
next question is so if if you
if if you could go back and speak to
21 year old rachel just left university
entered the recruitment industry
what would you say to her
um don't be so reactionary
to pick your battles i think that's
something
i've learned over the years um i think
it can be a really stressful environment
and when you're in a competitive
environment as well you may react
certain ways that you're not
particularly proud of so i would
probably say
um yeah pick pick your battles
try and be the best version of yourself
when things are going wrong
um you know don't take it to heart
so much no one's perfect i think that's
thing of me i'm always kind of striving
for
perfection in my job and when something
goes wrong i find it sometimes quite
hard to accept
what have i done there and i think it's
like no one's perfect
pick your battles um and
and yeah just just support everyone
around you basically because i think
we're all in it together
we all need to help help each other love
that
uh bit of a fun one this one what
what did you spend your first biggest
commission paycheck on
oh it doesn't even sound that big now
because it's back in 2009
it was an app one of those new what was
it the white
apple compute laptops what were they
called yeah yeah yeah yeah
i remember that apple max yeah sorry
yeah
yeah yeah because i've not had my ages
but at the white ones
if you remember the white yeah yeah all
right books i remember walking down yeah
world
and old kent road i think my commission
just come in and getting and getting
that absolutely buzzing
yeah love that right final question
what what's the ultimate goal for your
recruitment career
oh that's a good one
ultimate goal um
i guess to build a really successful
business and
and to to make a lot of money from it as
far as that sounds
i mean i i kind of have i have a vision
in mind of where i'd like to be
and like how to get there and that would
be via i guess
continually to to grow eventually and
just just being as profitable and
successful as possible
rachel i think you've been on a great
journey it's definitely inspiring and
yeah thank you so much for uh coming on
the podcast
thanks for having me it's been great